yeah yeah I'm serious
Oh the video starts now
this isn't like a super rare original
version of the book it's actually just
some kind of reprint from the 90s that I
got I think I got this in the back of an
action figure at some point but you know
it had sentimental value and I thought
it would be cool for him to sign it I
wonder what I'm gonna wear to Comic Con
tomorrow maybe there's a thinking juice
here baby
coming here that once again just used
brushstrokes and release
so what is your favorite Marvel
character right - right
Jamie man rocks and
there is a new spider-man
here
involvement
what color is
rumors if left
this one one
what's the whole quest
better
hobbies what are you
during the series
that's that
so I am turn Japanese punished
holy God okay for those who don't know
Punisher in the manga verse is a female
guy sho tickles crime bosses to death
with a whip
okay I'll tell you if you and your
Japanese
why we're not going to a
okay why is ace so tough
he's a badass
that leather jacket and glasses place is
basic
he was basically pretty
the artist is ruined
yeah basically
Marcus and sleepies
we broke even
hey first mark
holy crap grace
right for edge of time
boy with anti-venom bombing alchemax
well that answers it thank you was
really great well I should really get a
microphone for next year
professionalism what's that he did have
some pretty solid answers it was cool to
meet him he's a really awesome guy and
Peter David if you do somehow see this
thanks for putting up with me that was
my first interview ever and it was a
pleasure to meet you and I'm definitely
a really big fan of your work
ah yet another successful trip to one of
my favorite places in the world a giant
room full of sweaty people in costumes
awkwardly stumbling into each other
while buying overpriced merchandise for
things that will be irrelevant next year
now I'm just kidding I really do enjoy
Comic Con it's a place where you can
share a whole new culture with people
you can meet your idols make new friends
reunite with old friends and you can
take sleazy photos of every girl on a
slave Leia outfit sadly I didn't have a
ton of time to pull out the camera and
take footage or pictures because my
friend kept yelling at me saying don't
be that guy from found-footage horror
movies who keeps being obnoxious and
filming everything before the monster
shows up which is pretty fair all the
footage after the interview in this
video was recorded by my friend David
because he went an extra day and needed
something to do seriously David I can't
thank you enough you really saved my ass
this video was almost just the interview
plus like four minutes of a black screen
so you know thanks for looking out buddy
so I have a fun game for you
try and find me in any pictures of
Denver Comic Con this year because I
don't have a single one the only
pictures I got were after I got home and
was covered in sweat and regretful angst
just go to Facebook and look up Comic
Con or something it'll be like Where's
Waldo but with a ginger spider-man I'd
be surprised if you could find any this
was a record-breaking year for the
convention and I only went one of the
three days or just not do that because
why would you waste your time scouring
hundreds of photos for some random d-bag
on the Internet
so the thing is I don't think this is
actually a genuine DVD that they sold in
stores I think is some kind of super
illegal bootleg that someone just tossed
together so if I ever wanted to actually
review this the footage that I'd get
from it may run the risk of having like
a Cartoon Network or Disney XD logo in
the bottom of it he offers to help him
find planets fit for consumption yet not
containing life comma The Herald of
Galactus it's it's a better call Saul
figure but I've been watching that
series lately
and while its no breaking bad it's
pretty good look it's the more
successful one of the two Oedekerk
brothers cuz I guess the other one just
did kung pow and that was it wait did he
do Jimmy Neutron I can't remember you
know they should sell these and Toys R
Us I bet that'd go over well
okay so Karl Urban was there and I don't
have a single solitary thing for him to
sign you know and so I thought about
giving him this and then as soon as I
got up there just apologizing for not
having a Judge Dredd comic I never
actually made it there in time because
the line for Stan Lee was soem possibly
long when we got to meet Stan he was
very quiet and you know he actually is
not quite as energetic as he seems to be
in a lot of the movies I think his voice
sounds exactly the same it was cool
seeing him in person and you know just
getting a second to actually talk to him
speaking of being a nerd I also got a
whole bunch of art so yeah as a picture
of oh boy that's a lot glare this is
another one that's the same sort of
thing it's a picture of Tom Hollands
spider-man but it's very shiny and
chrome and it makes a cool noise and
this is a just a cool really so so uh
like subscribe favorite and share and
more and follow me on Twitter Instagram